Правляча партія «Слуга народу» на позачергових парламентських виборах
набирає у підсумку більше, ніж ще чотири, які проходять до парламенту.
Таких результатів в Україні не було ще ніколи.
В чому особливості цієї компанії?
Та які шанси чи-то загрози з'являться у політичному житті України?
Про говоритимем з головою правління громадянської мережі "Опора"
Ольгою Айвазовською. Доброго дня.
"Опора " вже 10 років спостерігає за перебігом виборчих процесів в Україні.
Чому ці вибори називають історичними?
Будь-які вибори в Україні називають історичними.
Якщо говорити про сам виборчий процес, він не є екстра-унікальним.
Радше навпаки. Втім, є одна новація.
На відміну від попередніх років, коли ми мали самодостатніх
кандидатів-мажоритарників від політичних партій або самовисуванців,
зараз ми маємо компанію, яка по суті
дискредитувала власне мажоритарну складову.
Тобто, мажоритарники, які перемогли на цих виборах,
вони все ж мали переважно партійну приналежність,
дуже часто не вели компанію, використовували єдину символіку,
відеоряди, ключові повідомлення національного рівня.
І тому, радше, ми зробили крок на зустріч
пропорційній системі без мажоритарної складової,
так, як вона і політично, і юридично досить себе вже дискредитувала.
Результати виборів. Що для Вас стало несподіванкою?
Це мажоритарна складова, яка перетворилася на цілком партійну,
коли неважливо було, наскільки кандидат-мажоритарник активний,
що він робив до цього, чи він фаховим, чи він навпаки
вдавався до недобросовісної, але дуже активної передвиборчої боротьби.
Тобто, зіграв бренд і бренд переміг.
В цьому є певна унікальна складова.
Чи є ризик, що центральні органи влади перейдуть
під контроль правлячої партії "Слуга народу "?
І навіть у разі створення коаліції не буде балансу думок?
Це не ризик, це - реальність. Нова політична реальність,
що в нас є політична партія, яка має абсолютну владу
і перспективу цю владу закріпити без будь-яких пересторог.
Якщо до неї долучаться ще народні депутати
з офіційними посвідченнями самовисуванців,
то вони отримають конституційну більшість
та не матимуть потреби долучати будь-яку малу політичну силу,
оскільки ця група має всю повноту влади на рівні президентської гілки,
парламентської та в перспективі урядової.
Чи буде вона використовувати це на користь країни та суспільства,
чи (лише) в межах власних потреб, завдань,
стратегій та інтересів, прогнозувати зараз ніхто не може.
Що буде робити опозиція? Чи є в неї шанс стати дієвою опозицією?
Опозиція , яка була до цього владою зробила колосальну помилку,
відмовившись від прийняття завчасно -не перед виборами, закону про опозицію,
оновлення парламенту, внутрішньо парламентську реформу,
яка б дала можливість пропорційно отримувати і опозиції,
і владі представництво в комітетах , очолювати
ці комітети, керівництві Верховної ради тощо.
Тобто, зараз все залежить від політичної волі абсолютної більшості,
чи буде опозиція долучатися до роботи на практиці
протягом найближчих трішки більше, ніж 4-х років.
Тому що каденція нового парламенту все ж буде коротше на 10 місяців, ніж 5 років.
Що буде для Вас особисто якимось індикатором,
що в новому парламенті, будуть дослуховуватися до позиції фракції?
Індикатором буде, очевидно, виконання регламенту ВР,
можливо, перегляду його частково, не порушення процедур.
Ті ініціативи, які зараз заявлені першочергові, викликають побоювання.
Наприклад, дуже популярна річ, як позбавлення
депутатської недоторканості і право громадян відкликати депутата.
З одного боку, це непогано. Це виглядає, як більше влади для виборця,
а ,з іншого боку, вона може застосовуватися в різний спосіб.
Для мене індикатором демократичності буде імперативний мандат.
Розмови, які про це ведуться,  або вони будуть реалізовані, або ні.
Тому що, якщо нова більшість - абсолютна більшість,
прийме це рішення, очевидно, проведене через парламент
очевидно, що більшість депутатів у складі цієї більшості,
будуть не самодостатніми гравцями і не самостійними.
Друге , це закон про тимчасові слідчі комісії,
тому що це реалізація функції контролюючої парламенту.
Найголовніше, що в цьому законі є і питання імпічменту президента,
тобто чинний президент, ідучи на попередню компанію, заявляв,
що потрібно мати цю процедуру, і вона давно вже на часі.
В парламент зайшли люди, котрі в політиці не були ніколи.
Як Ви ставитеся до їхнього  потенціалу?
Депутат-це є політик. Політик не обов’язково має бути фахівцем
питаннях екології, медицини, освіти, бюджетного процесу…
Новий політик має вивчити регламент  і Конституцію.
Конституцію, звичайно, вивчити першочергово.
Тому, я не бачу жодної трагедії в тому, що заходять люди , які некомпетентні.
Некомпетентних людей було завжди багато в парламенті.
Питання - хто буде очолювати  фракції, хто буде
створювати аналітичні  сприяння цим депутатам?
Їхні помічники, чи це будуть фахові люди в кожній сфері, яка важлива для депутата?
Чи у фракцій будуть аналітичні центри, так звані think-tanks,
де виробляється якась пропозиція для народних депутатів.
Чи будуть , насправді, засідання фракцій?
Чи всім по Viber, WhatsApp, Signal будуть розсилати, як голосувати, і на тому все.
Якщо на фракції немає обговорення, дискусії,
і спільно не виробляються позиція фракції,
то , звичайно, тут про компетентність взагалі немає сенсу говорити.
Можна бути компетентним депутатом і на ні що не впливати.
Можна бути некомпетентним і намагатися протягом
короткого періоду часу ці компетенції заробити і вивчитися.
За вашими даними, у день голосування були зафіксовано
приблизно вісімсот порушень. Чи багато це?
Можливо є такі, що Ви особисто назвали б найбільш кричущими?
Всі порушення є кричущими, але окремі можуть
вплинути на результат виборів, а окремі ні.
Якщо говорити  про процедурні, то їх було доволі багато.
В день голосування певні порушення навіть зменшилися
порівняно з президентськими виборами і тут спрацювало превенція.
Спрацювало те, що чинний президент, наприклад, був оштрафований
на президентських виборах, коли він продемонстрував
журналістам в приміщенні для голосування свій бюлетень,
де стояла галочка напроти нього. Тобто, розголосив
таємницю голосування, що мало ознаки також агітації.
А щодо вкидання бюлетенів, то такий факт був зафіксований в Донецькі області,
очевидно, що він має розслідуватися якісно правоохоронною системою,
але такі речі пішли вже в небуття з виборчого процесу.
Набагато ефективніше працює те, що має вплив на кінцевий результат
це підкуп , адмінресурс, незаконна агітація.
Адмінресурс за весь період- це було 44 факти нами зафіксовано.
По підкупу негрошовому - це 200 фактів, 202, якщо точно.
Грошових , щодо передачі грошей за голосування
за конкретного кандидата, ми не зафіксували.
Було два факти, які досліджувала правоохоронна система -поліція.
Там готувалися сітки, але виборцям ці гроші не дали.
Тобто цей процес не закінчився. Знов таки, по порушеннях,
які мають місце в окружних комісіях, їх багато.
І на жаль вони кримінальні.
Зараз усі говорять про цю діджиталізацію виборів.
Та чи є механізми контролю цих коштів,
які витрачаються на рекламу в Фейсбуці, рекламу в соцмережах?
ЦВК і НАЗК ,які мають функцію контролюючу, функцію регулятора.
Але вони взагалі не мають інструментів і практики моніторингу.
Для нас ,як для неурядової організації, не було проблемою
створити базу даних зі  сторінок верифікованих,  відслідковувати
на щоденній основі пости і рекламні повідомлення, заглядати в бібліотеку
цього повідомлення і знаходити суми, і хто за це заплатив,
тому що все це публічно. Facebook це відкриває.
Але ні ЦВК, ні НАЗК ці дані не перевіряє і не моніторить.
Тоді, наприклад, як чинний вже президент Зеленський
і політична партія " Слуга народу " перейшли в активній кампанії
з Facebook в Instagram ще на президентських виборах і зараз помітно,
що ,наприклад, " Голос " зробив ставку на Facebook ,
а "Слуга народу " і інші групи, які підтримують Зеленського, на Instagram.
Там немає інформації про оплату політичної реклами, хоча сама реклама є.
Коли Ви моніторили цю рекламу в соцмережах,
чи зафіксували якісь конкретні порушення?
В нас взагалі немає поняття Інтернет- агітації.
Тому, порушення в загальних позиціях фінансування, звичайно,
бо неправдиві дані включені в звіт фінансовий
в частині незаконних засобів фінансування виборів.
А вони можуть бути законними лише у випадку,
коли це сплачено з виборчих фондів.
Тому що ми не знаємо джерел цих грошей, ми не знаємо об’ємів,
але вони працюють краще, ніж  100000 біл-бордів.
Фактично порушили всі крім однієї маленької партії,
яка не пройшла в парламент, і вказали недостовірні відомості в звітах.
Потрібно вносити зміни до закону. Але на цю компанію
це вже ніяк не вплине і не пошириться.
Як спрацювали на виборців ці безкінечні концерти, участь у виборах зірок?
Насправді, зірки шоу-бізнесу завжди були у виборах
і співаки, артисти завжди агітували.
Але кількість наразі більша…
Ні, відмінність інша. Раніше співаки, актори не грали першу роль в цих процесах.
Тобто, вони були групами підтримки, вони були розвагою для виборців,
вони були засобом агітації, але не вони визначали: кого та як вони ведуть на вибори.
Самі актори та співки вперше стали лідерами.
Як Ви оцінюєте дії правоохоронців?
Як вони реагували на факти порушень
під час передвиборчої компанії, в день голосування?
Чи можна вважати, що були якісь випадки,
коли правоохоронці були заангажовані?
Я не думаю, що є докази заангажованості правоохоронців.
Цього разу ми з ними співпрацювали і це відкрита публічна інформація.
Тому моя оцінка може бути лише позитивно-партнерською.
У кожного з них була на руках інструкція,
яку ми спільно з юристами Нацполіції і МВС
розробили щодо ситуативних порушень в день виборів або провокацій,
повідомлень про замінування, вчинення певних дій
хуліганського характеру біля або всередині дільниць.
І вперше з 2015-ого ми маємо вироки, які адекватні до тих злочинів,
які інколи вчиняються під час виборів.
Чи були випадки перешкоджання або неможливості
взагалі роботи спостерігачів і преси?
Так, були. В нас є зафіксовані майже 10 випадків навіть фізичного протистояння.
Інколи це стосувалося дня голосування, інколи виборчої кампанії.
По суті, щодо цього ми зверталися в поліцію завжди, тому що це є
кримінальний злочин з відповідальністю досить серйозною.
20% нового парламенту – це жінки.
Це більше, ніж в попередньому скликанні.
Як Ви думаєте, як ці  жінки можуть змінити цей парламент?
Ми раді, що кількість жінок майже вдвічі зросла,
тому що в попередньому скликанні це 12% ,
зараз майже 21%, і 26 жінок обрано в округах.
Минулого разу обралися в округах лише дві жінки.
Це свідчить про конкурентність середовища для жінок, яке зростає.
І про те, що і суспільство трошки стає більш демократичним
і не дивиться на жінку – політика, як на вискочку,
або на ту, хто в якісь незрозумілий спосіб опинилася в політиці.
Щодо якості, я думаю, що зараз ще рано оцінювати якість парламенту,
тому що він оновиться на понад 80%, це дуже багато.
Чи давали у попередньому скликанні чоловіки
-нардепи працювати жінкам-нардепам?
Так. Ну що значить не давали? Звичайно, давали.
Я думаю, що жінки не запитували в чоловіків, чи можна ім працювати.
Вони захищали свої права.
Інколи траплялися хамські інциденти, коли деякі депутати
казали, що, мовляв, ви, жінка, прийшли
у чоловічій комітет псуєте нам тут конструктивну роботу.
Усе це має закінчуватися дисциплінарним розглядом комітету з питань етики.
Жінки захищали свої права, блокували трибуну,
робили публічні заяви щодо чоловіків-хамів.
Але це, на щастя, були поодинокі випадки.
В усіх інших процесах жінка має рівно стільки ж  прав
та можливостей, як і чоловік, якщо дотримуватися закону та регламенту.
Президент Зеленський планує провести позачергові місцеві вибори.
ЄС зауважує, що, можливо, вони не на часі.
Проведення позачергових виборів в межах чинного
закону і Конституції майже неможливе.
Тому, Верховній Раді та президенту доведеться
якось законно оформити свої політичні амбіції,
але тоді не йтиметься про верховенство права та демократію.
Якби навіть можна було уявити, що наприкінці року
на всій території України відбудуться позачергові місцеві вибори,
то це не означає, що в 2020 році не повинно бути чергових виборів.
Так каже Конституція. Тож я взагалі не бачу великої логіки
в тому, щоб протягом року організовувати дві
національні компанії з місцевих виборів.
Від цього можна більше програти, ніж виграти.
Чого ви очікуєте в політичному житті України упродовж наступних п'яти років?
Мені дуже б хотілося, щоб була реалізована виборча реформа.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що все ж відбудеться повноцінна реформа парламенту,
яка визначить роль влади і опозиції, яка пропорційно поділить комітети,
яка гарантує, що голос опозиції буде чутно.
Я дуже б хотіла, щоб над Конституцією не знущалися
просто в зв'язку з якимось політичними, ситуативним потребами.
Нас чекає багато випробувань, але сподіваюся, що суспільство
принаймні здатне на них адекватно реагувати.
Дуже дякую за інтерв’ю.
Дякую Вам.